direction Château-Renault à présent où
le maire et l'air s'emploie démentir
certaines rumeurs la dernière en date
une privatisation de la cantine scolaire
fake news répond Brigitte Dupuy qui
reconnaît seulement avoir embauché un
nouveau fournisseur le fait maison reste
la règle à tel insistée auprès de
parents venus eux-mêmes tester un repas
elle a une chapelet
ce midi
la moyenne d'âge n'est pas la même que
d'habitude parmi les enfants attabler
dans le réfectoire un groupe d'adultes
composé de parents d'élèves de Madame le
maire et du nouveau prestataire
technique de la cantine depuis le 1er
janvier la commune a recours à une
société Jocondienne valeur culinaire
pour élaborer ses menus son gérant c'est
lui et il est venu rassurer les parents
d'élèves en leur faisant tester le menu
du jour trois mamans ont accepté
l'invitation c'est le cas de Mélanie on
aime bien savoir ce que mange nos
enfants quand même le midi et non de
voir que c'est du fait maison que c'est
bon que les enfants apprécient on a les
morceaux dans la soupe donc c'est de la
soupe maison voilà donc c'est agréable
sur les menus on risque bien c'est que
là on voit vraiment ils mettent des
petits logos ce qui est fait maison ce
qui est bio la viande elle est française
d'où ça vient et on n'avait pas ça avant
sur sur le menu on n'avait pas autant de
visibilité
en coulisse toujours trois agents de
production salariés de la mairie ils
doivent cuisiner l'entrée le plat
principal et le dessert pour environ 300
écoliers toutes les recettes ont été
revues par le nouveau prestataire avec
encore plus de faits maison aujourd'hui
la salade de fruits est réalisée sur
place hier c'était une salade de fruits
en pot individuel ou un fruit que les
enfants devaient éplucher le même
centrale était en autogestion
effectivement il y avait pas de dessert
fait maison
aujourd'hui voilà quand on aura du riz
au lait à la carte ça sera un riz au
lait fait maison tout ce qui est semoule
ce sera la même chose des petites crèmes
au caramel en fait c'est un petit peu
retour à l'ancienne on va dire les
goûters avec du pain du chocolat les
produits vraiment du territoire mais on
souhaitait vraiment qu'une cuisine qui
soit faite maison pour nos petits de la
maternelle et du primaire
le contrat avec le nouveau prestataire
est conclu pour une durée d'un an avant
une possible reconduction plus longue
pas de changement du côté des prix il
resteront à 3,10 et 3 euros 20 pour les
petits Castels Renaudin